hi I'm Chris I'm some hey there are
marks I'm Oliver I'm Tristan today we're
gonna do a calendar style male model
shoot inspired by the war hours I
thought they were just there to make us
feel bad about ourselves I didn't wait
to raise money the idea was to make and
they kind of do another how many times
have you seen each other's dicks
multiple no well every day I read about
three is in the gate we teacup behind
the cup and starts putting color there
by about 2 years gave us in the Polish
article campaigns for allies which is
campaign combating homophobia in sport
just to be clear you guys are athletic
good-looking British and give to a cause
but you guys there's a twist
there's I'm gonna be BuzzFeed inspired
photoshoots and we're gonna surprise you
with what you're posing with right as
you step onto the set we've shown our
butts to the world now let's show the
world the rest of us for Keith's photo
shoot the theme is going to be cash
grumpy cats are just cats that like
sweat
here we have a girl coming in that's
gonna be Taylor Swift no you're gonna be
Taylor Swift
[Music]
peeps that's like my second favorite
thing in the world
what's your first mom Pizza everything
else Harry Potter you kind of look like
him a 12 year old I think I'm gonna be
the hairiest harry potter ever I'm
allergic to cat Harry Potter is what got
me into reading so it's only right that
Harry Potter gets me into nude modeling
guys ready yeah all right don't feel bad
[ __ ] what how good are you at Photoshop
can you guys make like ocean sounds for
me so are you guys constantly flexing
your abs are we getting naked we don't
feel like I should all right well we're
here let's [ __ ] do it
I aim a little to the left is that
normal - there's our first pose is cast
get the chemicals in there what makes a
cat say he's on to become the car give
me a house cat fear old rabid cat that's
like foaming at the mouth in a Barack
Obama cat give me Queen of England cat I
want to be like knocked over here so and
tonic he shares a cat style yoga pose
yeah look at the line almost about well
we're trying to [ __ ] this guy yeah
perfect
so keep put that around cut the cat cut
the keep cat that's not good at here no
it flex your muscles a little bit sexy
cat okay what is the plan with the milk
you thirsty
[Music]
we also have some swept ease back here
who've got some more props oh and
everyone is my lover mm-hmm I like that
we're missing something
yeah got it got the looks down we're
longing towards - yeah you want you need
the love towards me you guys are like
Harry Styles and you're like damn I
missed out he's always like covering up
yeah you're like oh my god I'm so
surprised somebody's hand is down my
pants I'm getting some scruff on my
shoulder I'm literally being fought over
this is how Taylor Swift music videos
should be ah somebody hit my dick
everybody should feed an apple to
somebody else
exactly what's a modeling mode do it
just above the camera through it okay
there's the prettier Taylor Swift me
very Taylor Swift we got a special
delivery for you guys yeah Eugene don't
be afraid of the pizza I just want to
eat it though how about we go
progressively research the delivery
person was super hot and all you can
think about is damn this is like sex
doing this one back yeah the cheese
isn't cheese it's sex cheese you're
staying where you are but feed Eugene
one slice whatever there's one Asian
person and a porn they always end up in
this position why don't we just cover me
and as much pizza as possible Oh pizza
on my big night if my pizza hat on fleek
and your pizza game is strong
I think this dragon string in here nine
and a half inches of Oh generous but I
think this is my good side I'm trying to
intimidate holding work with my six yes
the context you guys are all
Dumbledore's Army and Harry's ass is the
biggest weapon in that room fell like
this is JK Rowling watching I'm so sorry
Joe so surprised and seductive I don't
know if it's that I'm comfortable being
naked around strangers or at this point
there's just no boundaries left across
for us the worst camera angle and I feel
like you guys didn't have a full
experience
I wasn't presented this option at all I
would have taken it I would have taken
it as well like we have to yeah okay
ourselves in the work rowers skin how do
you think we did no future in space if
you like what you see and you'd like to
see more it's a nice calendar tells you
what day it is and we're naked